[Música]
y hablamos de revista de prensa en
directo américa de france 24 como todos
los días hoy lunes comenzamos una semana
más con rosa pressmás de uva la dueña y
la encargada de esta sección rosa vamos
por supuesto hablar de lo que ocurrió el
día de ayer domingo 10 de abril en esta
primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales francesas y vamos
entonces a comenzar con el diario le
monde empezamos con la prensa local para
después ir al internacional y hacíamos
poco a poco
buenos días raúl exactamente y
felicidades feliz cumpleaños gracias
rositas gracias gracias vamos al tema
que nos ocupa como decías empezamos por
lo mont que titula macro lepén una
segunda vuelta más incierta y en el
editoriales del mismo medio lamenta que
sea la tercera vez en 20 años que la
extrema derecha llega a la segunda
vuelta presidencial
recordemos que en 2002 fue el padre de
marín lópez fran marie le pen quien
llegó también al balotaje y que su hija
ha recogido un poco del relevo y se
presenta de forma más des diaboliza da
como dice ella y este medio señala que
cada vez que llega a la la derecha a
esta segunda vuelta lo hace con más
apoyos y para eso llama a una
responsabilidad histórica vamos ahora a
ver qué dice liberación liberación como
siempre con estos titulares y estas
portadas tan impactantes dice esta vez
da miedo de verdad y también señala esto
no una extrema derecha reforzada y
destaca que a diferencia de en 2017
emanuel macro en el actual presidente
puede tener más dificultades para
congregar lo que se llama el voto del
cordón sanitario no que en francés le
llaman barras de barrera a la extrema
derecha porque dice después de un
quinquenio de un mandato marcado por
políticas de derecha ahora va a tener
más dificultades para captar el voto de
la izquierda no un voto también que ayer
consiguió por muy poquito bueno no
consiguió por muy poquito llegar también
a la segunda vuelta con melanson a las
puertas de este balotaje vamos ahora con
le figaro le figaro este medio de
derechas también abiertamente llama eso
sí pues al cordón sanitario y dice que
si bien
cron está un poquito por delante del epp
en todo puede pasar porque la diferencia
está pues más ajustada que nunca y vamos
ahora con la aparición le parisian
también unas titula en el mismo sentido
en el mismo sentido dice partido de
vuelta en pequeña ventaja por parte de
macrón y es que recordemos los últimos
sondeos de opinión dan incluso una
diferencia de dos puntos en intención de
voto no de cara a esta segunda vuelta
cuando en 2017 macrón logró cosechar el
66% de los apoyos en el balotaje vamos a
ver pues lo que pasa el 24 de abril
trouble vamos a ver lo que va a pasar
este próximo 24 de abril y cerramos la
prensa nacional con mediapart sí porque
media parte se centra en la situación de
la izquierda entonces tras esta primera
vuelta en que como comentábamos pues el
partido la francia e insumisa liderada
por milán son pues se consiguió muchos
más apoyos de los que le otorgaban los
sondeos pero se quedó a las puertas de
no poder sustituir a la extrema derecha
en la contienda electoral para disputar
pues el elíseo a manuel macro ni eso por
la desunión de la izquierda en que puede
ser por menos de dos puntos no se logró
pues sea conseguir más apoyos que la
extrema derecha y vamos a ver ahora como
titula todo esto la prensa internacional
y comenzamos con alemania rusa sí porque
el frankfurter allgemeine este medio
europeo este medio de alemania pues
destaca que esta contienda no es sólo
importante para francia sino para la
composición de toda la unión europea por
otro lado tenemos también el país de
españa que entre otros a titulares
destaca la caída no de los partidos
tradicionales franceses tanto de los
republicanos como de los socialistas
vamos también con la república de italia
que entró entre otras cosas pues
destacan las estrategias tanto de macrón
como del epen para conseguir el voto
obrero ahora de cara a esta segunda
vuelta y también destaca que es el look
milán son el candidato de izquierdas fue
el más votado entre los jóvenes de entre
18 y 34 años
seguimos porque en el aquí en américa
latina' el espectador también lleva en
portada no esta contienda electoral
francesa y es de los pocos medios que
destaca que si la izquierda hubiera
estado unida no tendríamos a la extrema
derecha en la segunda vuelta y por
último cerramos con el 'new york times'
que bueno dice que la extrema derecha
amenaza a la actual presidente de la
republica de manuel macrón y hay que ver
el papel que acaba jugando la abstención
o como decíamos las dificultades de cada
uno de los candidatos para cosechar los
votos de la izquierda y algo que nos
gusta rosa es ver las caricaturas
después de hitos tan importantes como
son unas elecciones presidenciales en un
país como comenzamos esto pues empezamos
con esta caricatura en las reviews de
cine que muestra esta escena tan
cotidiana no enviando la tele un domingo
por la noche en la que una persona pide
la otra queda que hacen en la televisión
y el otro dice pues todavía un remake no
y el otro dice nulo remake pues un
remake de esta segunda vuelta de 2010
por otro lado tenemos también la
ilustración que hemos seleccionado de
limón con el que en la que vemos al
primer ministro de santes text que le
pregunta al presidente manuel macro
entonces usted es la izquierda en la
segunda vuelta con este puesto que
bastante irónico no y por último tenemos
100 mediapart en que vemos que manuel
macro no tiene que convencer para que lo
voten a todas las personas a las que ha
despreciado a lo largo de su mandato no
vemos aquí puede ser las distintas
personas a las que ahora pide que voten
por el tanto a los islam o izquierdistas
como las que dijo que no eran nada como
los que les dijo que el cruzaba la calle
y encontraba trabajo así es rosa gracias
entonces a por toda la información esta
revista de prensa nos vemos mañana con
más ustedes continúen con nosotros ya
vamos
[Música]